this book you you were unsparing in this
book you talk about the highs the lows
and what's pretty compelling which I
think most people don't realize is that
Arrowsmith you guys get started you're
one of the biggest rock and roll acts in
the 70s hugely successful and then you
guys all fell on hard times to the point
where you were forced to sell your
favorite guitar now I'm a guitar buff
it's a 1959 Les Paul this was a guitar
that was your guitar that you used on
all these classic songs that everybody
here knows and you had to sell that
guitar well it was C 1980 I just left
the Aerosmith and it was Christmas time
and I needed some bread and I chose
plays Stratocasters a lot right around
then and that was the best guitar to
sell I could get rid of it pretty quick
because they are very rare and like I
said you know the value to them so
anyway I sold it and really didn't think
much of you probably sold it for not
nearly what not a fraction of what you
would get for it today well let's just
say I didn't bid it out you know I mean
there was no eBay or anything like that
right and I just called up my one of my
deal of friends anyway
so time went on in over the years the
band got back together again and we
started starting to have some success
again and I thought made it be a good
idea to maybe if I could find some of
those old guitars that had gone the way
of the wind you know so I started
looking for this one and I had all my
guitar tech so looking everywhere and
Brad walks in and said I know where your
guitar is and he opens up a guitar
magazine and the centerfolds had Slash's
guitar collection and right in the
middle was that guitar so slash had
ended up with your guitar you changed
hands and it ended up in his his hands
and he made no bones about the fact that
he's been a fan of the band and
boy when I when I here I called him up
and he was like oh please don't ask me
man don't ask me that you know did you
say I'll buy it back I thought I said
I'll pay whatever you want for it
because it did like doubled in price by
then and right and and he said listen
I'll think about it so I called him back
and over a series of months go by and
I'm talking to him and you know every
I'd asked him and then finally he
stopped taking my calls I finally I had
that I had to sit him down just put his
hat over the phone and I knew it was
getting in the way of our friendship and
I said look I'll never ask you about it
again man I just what if you ever want
to sell it back just just you know give
me a call whatever but I'm not gonna bug
you about it and at my 50th birthday
cheap trick was playing they came in to
play and I sat in with them and in the
middle of the set my guitar check walks
up and hands me this guitar and it was
the guitar and slash gave it to me
slash game appeal
personal experiences we've done a lot of
grits I've done a lot of things with
Slash and he is one of the nicest guys
you'll ever meet it's hard so big I
don't know how it fits this chest yeah
he's amazing
yeah that's a scary description we've
got to get slashed some medical
attention
you